Everything you own from your clothes to
your car to your wife or your husband is
going to forget you and move on and be
replaced the moment you die. That's why
Allah says
you are busy with the worldly affairs
until you visit the graves. Brothers and
sisters, masid Norway, the one that we
built is looking to another masid around
the area of Norway. Subhan Allah. Where
there's so many Muslims that do not have
somewhere to pray. This masjid is only
$500,000 and any donation that you give
will go towards your because when you
enter that grave, nobody's going to
remember you except Allah subhanaa tala.
So make it count brothers and sisters
and donate towards this message
inshallah a new project that's only
$500,000 and believe me if every single
one of us give £1, £10, £100, £1,000
that's going to be something you will
never regret on your makayama and
everything that you lose is going to
perish and go. But your deeds and your
makyama are not. Donate to the link
inshallah. Let's get to the video.
Brothers and sisters, dear friends, you
may have seen the video of the shooting
that happened in uh San Diego. And I
done a video covering it. Subhan Allah.
And then I came across this disgusting,
disgusting, vile,
shameless individual, Laura Luma. And
this is unbelievable because you know
they say every accusation is a
confession. Every accusation is a
confession. There was a march a couple
of days ago where these fire rights,
most of them are behaved. Some of them
coming here and talking about pedophilia
and this that. And I thought, subhan
Allah, you guys are the main culprits of
pedophilia. Every single one of you guys
look like the main culprits. It's as if
every accusation they follow is a
confession. Look at this evil Zionist
dirt bag. Look what she says. The
shooting in California took place at a
jihadi mosque known for his hate
preachers.
This shooting was likely planned by
Muslims and the Islamic lobby in America
to spread more Islamophobia laws and
create sympathy for Islamic invaders in
America. It's all bull crap. Don't
engage.
Just imagine. Just imagine she can get
away with that. Just imagine a shooting
happens or Jewish people and then I call
it that this happened in a Zionist
synagogue.
Basically justified it. This happen Z
syn synagogue and it is all you know
done by the Zionists to give sympathy to
themselves. I will be hanged upside
down. Believe me, I would be oh my gosh.
Like like if they had their abilities,
they'll hang me off. They'll crucify me.
They'll crucify me. Look at she just can
say this. And she's a vile person. And
Allahh has already communicated that
with you know uh
she looks like that movie the the s she
looks like that like look at this vile
shameless person trying to say that the
Muslims orchestrated killing their own.
You know where this is coming from guys?
Every accusation is a confession. This
is coming from them because you know why
the Zionists, Mossad, Israelis are known
for this. They are known for this.
They've done this in Iraq. I covered in
another video in different places. They
would attack their own communities,
attack the Jews so they don't feel safe
so they can return to Israel. There's
documented files throughout history them
attacking their own their own. Yes.
these Zionists attacking innocent Jewish
people are there the innocent people
they don't know what's going on so they
can say return back to Israel so you're
safe here you see you have land save
here they would plant bombs and explode
them so they can say look it's not safe
for you to live here you're safe there
they will do this all around the world
it's documented it's all I've done a
video about it inah so every accusation
is a confession and because they do this
she thinks everyone's like that because
she if someone's a thief thinks
everyone's a thief can I just borrow
your phone oh no it's going to steal my
phone cuz you know why cuz they will
steal their people's
Laura Luma, you are a nobody. The whole
world is waking up to the Zionist fraud
and the whole world is waking up. We're
going to find the motives of these two
shooters of why they did what they done.
Yes. And we're going to find out who
they were inspired by. You might be one
of those. May Allah bless brothers and
sisters Amin brother Amin who died in
the course.
Check my video about that in powerful
reminder. Subhan Allah. May Allah grant
him the high strength of Jenna. Till
next time. Where to get to?